هجره اسراليه جديده وكبيره هنا في مدينه
رفح بعد قصف مربع سكني بسلسله غارات عنيفه
طالت منزلا ومسجدا هنا في مخيم الشعود هذا
المشهد امامكم شاحنه انقلبت بفعل الغاره
في مكان سكني مقتض بعشرات المواطنين هذا
هو المسجد يعرف باسم مسجد علي في مخيم
الشعود في مدينه رفح دمر المسجد عن بكره
ابيه ومنازل مجاوره بفعل هذه الغار
الجويه العنيفه او سلسله غارات على الاقل
سبعه من الصواريخ هنا طالت هذا المسجد
ومنازله محيطه وادى ذلك الى سقوط عدد كبير
من الشهداء وايضا الجرحى بفعل هذه الضربات
الجويه المفاجئه كثير من الشهداء هم من
الطرقات ومدارس ايواء قريبه من مكان القصف
الاسرائيلي الذي كان مباغتا
ومفاجئا بسبعه صواريخ تلق اطلقتها مقاتلات
الاحتلال الحربيه يتم البحث الان عن
المفقودين اسفل ركام هذا المنزل وهنا
مركبات مدنيه كانت تسير على الطريق عند
الغارات الجويه واصحابها ما بين شهداء
ومصابين ومفقودين في هذه الغارات الان
وصول طواقم الدفاع المدني الفلسطيني الى
المكان للمشاركه في عمليات البحث
والانتشار في هذا المكان الذي تعرض
لهذه السلسله من الغارات الجويه الاسريه
العنيفه
والمكثف انتشار احد الشهداء
الان كما نشاهد في هذه المجزره الكبيره
هنا في وسط مدينه
رفح مجزره كبيره تغبها قوات الاحتلال
بقصفها لهذا المربع السكني والمسجد بسلسله
غرا صار احنا نازحين من مدينه ابد حانون
لكن مراكز الاواه في رف
جيش الاحتلال اعلمنا واحنا في بيت حنون في
المدارس بيت حنون مراكز الاواء في بيت
حنون ومعسكر جباليه روحوا بعد وادي غزه
على رفع خانيونس على الدايره احنا جينا
على الرفع في داخل مراكز الاواء خمس مراكز
ايواء للور وبجانبهم المسجد وفي داخل
المسجد مصلين وفي حوالين المسجد نازحين
رايحين على السوق بجانب المسجد نزل عليهم
مسجد هل عليهم وهل علينا حطهم من مراكز
الاواء مراكز الاواء ليست امنه رفح ليست
امنه غزه ليست امنه اليهود جيش الاحتلال
كذاب كذاب مرافق نحن داخل المدارس في
اطفال ايش دخل الطفل عشانه بقول كلمه لا
اله الا الله واحنا مع كلمه لا اله الا
الله محمد رسول الله ونحن مع المقاومه
ولسنا يعني في حر مع اليهود في عراق يوم
الدين لن نطلع من غزه وسنرجع لبيت حانون
ومعسكر جباليه وسنحيا بيت حانون ونعمر
بيوتنا باذن الله في بيت حانون العرب لحت
الان 20 الف شهيد و 200 ال مصاب معاقين
اعاقات ليش ليش يا احتلال وين العرب وين
الملايين حبي الله ونعم الوكيل وما زالنا
نقول لا اله الا الله ونحارب في غزه
ونقاوم في غزه ونحن في عراق لا يومين مع
جيش الاحتلال نحن في تحت الردم تحت الردم
امواد كلهم اطفال كلهم شيوخ لا في مقاومه
فرفح رفح مشش فيها مقاومه احنا المقاومه
رفح مشش احنا المقاوم وسنقوم ونحن مع
المقاومه باذن الله ولن تسقط المقاومه هنا
تمكن التواق الدفاع المدني من انتشال هذا
الشاب بصعوبه بالغه من تحت الركام ويتم
الان البحث عن اخر في نفس المكان ونقله
وفي السيارات الاسعاف مشهد مؤلم وقاسي جدا
لهؤلاء المدنيين الابرياء الذين استشهدوا
اثناء المرور من هذا المكان بعد قصله من
قبل الطرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه ارات اسرائيليه عنيفه على
مدينه رفح هنا الجنوبيه قطاع غزه مقع
عشرات الشهداء والجرحى ه الشاعر بقناه
الجزيره مدينه رفح vai